okay we got a question from james
wall shammy sure
i'd love a discussion around the
benefits of lifting shoes
with with a raised heel what does it do
on a squat versus a leg press
i'm thinking the main difference is to
do with the trunk in the squat
question mark so what do you think about
olympic weightlifting shoes with an
elevated heel for the squat and for the
leg press
yeah so starting starting with the squat
um mechanically
so kind of just if we assume
humans operate as simple machines
the primary thing that squatting with a
raised heel will do for you
is allow more forward knee travel and
allow your torso to be slightly more
upright if you have uh
ankle mobility restrictions if you don't
have ankle mobility restrictions
theoretically squatting in a flat-soled
shoe versus a shoe with a raised heel
should be virtually identical um
and so so in terms of who i would
pretty strongly recommend uh to at least
try squatting with a raised heel
it would primarily be people with ankle
mobility restrictions
like i said that's if we assume that
humans are just simple machines
something to note though is that um
much like in a previous episode we
talked about
how um a small difference in cueing or
just a very small change in
positioning for a lift can
subjectively make it feel quite
different uh
either a lot stronger or just
subjectively feel a lot better and more
comfortable
i think that same principle applies when
we're talking about
lifting shoes so
it is not uncommon for
a lifter to um
like habitually squat in in one kind of
shoe put on another kind of shoe
you take a video of the squat squat
looks basically the same
but one just feels way way better or way
way worse
so even if
even if you don't have ankle mobility
restrictions and
your squat kinematically is
is virtually identical with a flat soled
shoe versus a raised heel
you may still strongly prefer one to the
other and so
so i do think that um even if there's
not
something that looks like it should be
an obvious benefit i still think it's
worth
most lifters playing around with
with squatting with a raised heel just
to see if like
anecdotally for themselves that feels
better
um and then for squat versus leg press
so eric and i were talking about this
before we started recording
because uh while i do have some raised
heel squat shoes
i i never like press um
or i haven't leg pressed uh consistently
in probably a decade
so i don't think i've ever worn my squat
shoes on a leg press
um but what eric said made a lot of
sense and
he said it it basically just depends on
the angle of the leg press platform so
some leg presses if you're um
like before you start going down your
ankles will will basically be in neutral
like
you know your the angle of your foot
coming off of your
shank will be like 90 degrees um
and in that case wearing a shoe with an
elevated heel
will likely allow for
greater depth on the leg press and more
forward knee travel
again if you do have ankle mobility
restrictions
but then a lot of leg presses the um
the platform that your feet rest on
are already angled so even with a flat
soled shoe
it gives you the effect of as if you
were already wearing a raised heel
and in that situation you're kind of
stacking a raised heel
on top of a faux raised heel just from
the leg press platform
and it can feel like leg pressing in
high heels and
just generally feel weird and and i
guess theoretically could like
hyper extend your ankle like probably
not enough to
hurt it but enough to put it in kind of
a weird and uncomfortable
range of motion so yeah i think for the
leg press it it kind of
kind of depends on how the leg press you
use is built
and specifically the angle of the
platform yeah i mean it gets a little
uncomfortable sometimes because
it's like you're starting the leg press
with
a reasonable amount of plantar flexion
at the ankle and uh yeah you almost feel
like you're pushing
over the platform then through it once
once you get to a certain level of
plantar flexion
it's a very uncomfortable feeling if
there's like a severe angle on that but
uh if it's nice and flat it it feels
very similar to
to squatting in a in an elevated